after putting a first-half freeze on the
record setting Broncos of
the Seattle defense was proving that
defense wins championships
ceptin Richard Sherman can really play
that was a beautiful intercept
however the high-powered Broncos would
not go away so easily phone as the
temperature inside MetLife Stadium
dropped many times
he doesn't kick with the to score leave
Denver as it had done on several
occasions throughout the season simply
would not put their report away he's got
a little bit of daylight here the 20 the
10 touchdown after rallying for too late
schools Seattle would need a two-point
conversion to send the game to overtime
gonna take it
are going to overtime the Seahawks would
head into overtime with the momentum and
the way for the Denver defense and other
ideas and they sack him on third down
they forced the quick three and out if
Peyton Manning was going to cap this
historic season he paints his legacy now
was the time
to the special teams right here